had acted more forcefully with the
president
that's a bound to be a controversial
book
and it's a very interesting story
well thank you very much for your time
both of you
good luck
and now author ronald kessler discusses
his book the fbi inside the world's most
powerful law enforcement agency he
focuses on the day-to-day workings of
the federal bureau of investigation
since j edgar hoover's death in 1972
mr kessler details watergate the events
that led to the dismissal of former fbi
director william sessions the 1988 pan
am 103 bombing in lockerbie scotland and
the investigation following the bombing
of the world trade center in february of
nineteen ninety three
from book notes in nineteen ninety three
this program is about an hour
ronald kessler what does roast beef and
the fbi have to do with one another
has a lot to do with the fbi and and
it's also a funny story um
an agent in new york wanted to have
lunch and he went around the
field office around the corner and went
to a deli that he thought was one of
those establishments that offers a
special deal to fbi agents either a
discount or more food or whatever so he
went in and he ordered a roast beef
sandwich and the countermen piled on the
slices and then he
shoved it over towards towards him when
the fbi agent looked at it and it just
didn't look like anything special it
wasn't any any huge amount of meat at
all so he pulled out his fbi credentials
and he said fbi more risk beef
and the cameraman just sort of looked at
him he didn't know what what he was
talking about because it wasn't one of
those special establishments but the
story soon spread all around the fbi all
around its field offices and and
throughout the world
uh because it tells you a lot about the
fbi and and agents you know just
breaking appeals of laughter when they
hear it uh and that is that um with
those credentials with the official
authority of the fbi you can do what
superman does almost you know you can
wiretap you can break into homes you can
even shoot people under certain
circumstances you can get all this
damaging information from the files you
can
bypass airport security you can get into
movies free on and on but it has to be
done with official authority with
approval by the bureau and not to get
more roast beef
but you know the the story
continues because
when agents are dissatisfied with
anything they say more roast beef
or
if they want to tell their supervisors
that they show their credentials they
say i roast beefed him so it's just sort
of a great legend and the truth isn't
quite that i actually found the
individual who was responsible for this
for this
little uh
gambit and
he claims it was actually a corned beef
sandwich and there were a few other
details that he says were slightly off
but
basically it was a true story
after talking to fbi agents
uh where is their number one choice to
go with the fbi
in terms of future duty
ah
it often just depends on on where their
hometown is they like you know they
frequently like to end up uh back home
uh the the the last place they want to
go to is new york because
they don't like the violent crime
they're not not that they they don't
want to
uh pursue those kinds of cases but just
in terms of getting mugged on the way to
work
it's not much fun and
living costs are high
and some of the most bizarre personnel
incidents occur in new york
because every other chapter or so is
about a city in your book let me just
ask you about some of these places and
what
were the things that got your attention
in each place let's pick dallas
dallas had a wonderful case involving
the banditos this motorcycle gang that
that would
kill people
engage in drugs
all kinds of things thefts and in order
to
penetrate this the fbi took over a bar
and actually operated it and eventually
made a profit and an agent working
undercover was the bartender and
supposedly the owner of the bar and it
was it became a hangout for the banditos
and so the whole place was wired and
video cameras all over and and uh
everything that went on was was taped
and they would discuss their deals they
were discussed you know when they're
going to
hijack uh some truck or or or
even murders that they committed
and every night the agent would
uh dictate reports to another agent and
eventually uh almost a hundred bandidos
in in four or five states were arrested
as a result of that uh but but one of
the one of the most difficult parts of
it was uh trying to avoid some of the
uh various presents that these bandidos
offered the bartender because
uh
they befriended him and and one of the
best presents that they could offer was
a lovely young girls who were sort of
part of their harem each each bandito
would have four or five girls who would
be so-called girlfriends and so they
would want to
offer sexual favors to this fbi agent
and he had to try to finesse his way out
of it because he couldn't very well do
that but at the same time he didn't want
to seem to be
you know a law enforcement type who who
didn't want to engage in that type of
thing
so those are some of the little
frustrations that you encounter in the
fbi go back in in this story uh
in dallas to start with how is that a
big office
uh it's about a medium-sized office
where is it located
it's um let's see
oh it's in some nice new part of town i
remember you're writing about west end i
mean did you go there do you travel
these places right yeah uh yeah but you
know it all starts to run together after
a while it's probably not fair for me to
pick out
you know specifics in here but go back
to the the fbi and in a place like
dallas they live well there
are the houses nice
yeah
it's over a nice mexican restaurant and
uh it's it's fairly nice you know
carpeting and
you know very high security devices of
course
and go back to that story though about
the banditos um how do they buy a bar
how does the fbi bio and whose idea was
it to do something like that
uh they
had a previous owner who wanted to give
it up and so they made a deal with her
whereby
uh she would keep the liquor license in
her name but but the fbi would operate
it and would assume all liability uh
eventually just sort of disappeared i
guess because
she didn't want it back
and
uh the idea you know typically will will
originate you know either in the field
uh
in in a field office or
in this case i think it was in
headquarters where the idea originated
uh and the agent actually was based in
new york and they saw they purposely
brought him in from another city so that
he wouldn't be recognized
and what was the purpose what were they
after
uh they were after real hard evidence
that they could show to a jury that
would convict these people you know
these days juries are used to seeing
videotapes or tape or listening to tape
recordings they don't want to hear
uh witnesses and a lot of times
witnesses are wrong i mean the best way
is to have basically a sting operation
which is
uh
where you can videotape everything that
happens and
how did they i mean was there an
individual that went there and ran it
and took over as far as everybody that
came in there thought he was the owner
right it was this one agent who was uh
undercover and and he would have long
hair and and he was a real tough guy and
he had a lot of experience in running
bars because before he joined the fbi he
had actually operated some bars in new
orleans
and the fbi does in fact like to get
eight new agents who have some kind of
professional background in almost
anything whether it's jewelry or or or
running bars
because uh that can often be used in
these undercover operations did you go
to this bar no by the time i did the
book it was closed how old a story is
this by the way i i think it went down
about five or six years ago and you say
they put cameras and recording devices
well if you sat at the bar all those
conversations could be heard that's
right yeah is this legal
oh yeah they would they would get court
approval for for intercepting
conversations uh in that way of course
in this case since the fbi basically
owned it
they could they could probably do it all
by themselves but whenever whenever they
do electronic interception they get a
court order
how many fbi agents are there in the
country
there are 10 300 agents and then about
23 000 total employees including those
agents
what kind of power do they have
it's a lot you know it's it's uh much
more than any local police department
for sure and uh probably more than most
foreign law enforcement agencies in part
because of the tremendous resources that
the fbi has the fbi laboratory you know
which is which is so advanced and
the
the fact that they can call on resources
of other
law enforcement agencies interpol the
cia so if anybody's gone overseas they
can they can track them down that way
there are tremendous techniques that
that they use such as profiling of
criminal uh suspects in serial murder or
rape cases
where they actually describe in great
detail who the
subject probably was and then they
actually find that person
which isn't to say that they don't make
mistakes and and there are a lot of
screw-ups and embarrassing incidents
that occur but but overall they're very
successful as we saw in the world trade
center bombing case recently and also
the fact that they
aborted the planned bombing of the u.n
you have to have a special education of
any kind to be an agent
you have to have a four-year college
degree
which is different from a lot of other
law enforcement agencies
and then they usually
do take people who already have
established professional reputations
they've already even been stock brokers
or accountants or or lawyers was there a
time
i just vaguely remember there's a time
when either cia agents or fbi agents had
to be either lawyers or accountants
that wasn't one of the many myths under
the hoover regime uh that they all had
to be accountable lawyers in fact only
about roughly the same percentage as
today about fifteen percent of them are
lawyers and about fifteen percent of
them are accountants um but again uh you
know they really want a diverse
background anyway they don't they don't
want all lawyers or all accountants you
mentioned buck revell a lot who was he
he's still the head of the dallas field
office he was formerly
one of the top
high ranking
officials in the fbi uh for many many
years and he had a lot to do with with
uh
bringing the fbi into the modern era
after hoover
uh he's also known as someone who who
likes to put a lot of plaques on his
wall he he receives a lot of plaques and
so he's sometimes a butt of jokes when
he when he retired there were a lot of
jokes about that at his retirement party
um but uh he has a really brilliant mind
and and
a tremendous knowledge of the fbi so he
was a great resource
got any idea whether the fbi likes this
book
i think overall the more sophisticated
agents uh like it they think it's fair
and and they they
they've said it's dead on accurate in
fact they're made they're amazed at how
accurate it is uh uh i think more some
of the neanderthal types who are sort of
who still have that hoover mentality
that the bureau should never be
criticized and the bureau never does any
wrong or if it does we certainly don't
tell the public about it uh will not
like it no coffee
no coffee under hoover uh
you know one of those strange you know
endless uh
quirks that that hoover had which was
that uh he didn't allow agents to drink
coffee although clerks and secretaries
could have coffee and so
if you did drink were caught drinking
coffee on the job even outside of the
field office
you were
transferred frequently and many agents
were
they would all of course spend a lot of
time trying to circumvent that that rule
and go far away from the field office to
drink coffee thereby wasting even more
time why
well hoover uh you know had a lot of
things that are very hard to explain a
lot of uh
aspects to his personality i think there
was some
idea in his mind that that
agents
had to appear to be
these perfect specimens who who
didn't need to drink coffee that coffee
would be
seen as as being
wasteful or slovenly or or just somehow
not
in the image of the fbi
uh and there was so much emphasis under
hoover on this image
idea and his particular concept of of
what an agent should look like you know
pear-shaped uh heads were out
bald heads were out
chorus blacks were out females were out
uh
they had to look like ephraim zimblis jr
if if at all possible
and underneath all that image
there was
not a lot
that the bureau was doing the bureau was
spending most of its time trying to
catch car thieves and other minor
criminals just to generate statistics
that they could show to congress to show
how many arrests they made they're
trying to you know get bigger budgets
they were trying to maintain hoover's
position as director meanwhile the
really important
crimes that only the fbi can address
well
were being ignored such as organized
crime political corruption including
members of congress who were corrupt
even even local sheriffs hoover wouldn't
go after white-collar crime
and
even in
espionage cases
hoover confused
political dissidents with spine and so
the result was not only that that he
undermined the rights of americans by
going after political dissidents who had
not engaged in criminal behavior but
also uh didn't do a very good job of of
catching spies could this book have been
written if j edgar hoover was still
director of the fbi absolutely not i
would probably be
in
in some danger if i had written such a
book under hoover uh he would have a
so-called do not contact list of
reporters who
had written anything critical about the
fbi and they would not
have any uh help from the fbi whatsoever
and uh i had done some stories uh when
hoover was live in
uh the boston herald and and uh and even
the washington post which
which hoover didn't like
about
the fbi wiretapping illegally and about
the fbi keeping files on members of
congress for blackmail purposes and that
earned some critical comments in my fbi
file from hoover
uh have you looked at your file i have
uh and they're in there little scribbles
from hoover some of which are
indecipherable but but they they
definitely were not praised
um what kind of things are in a file
like yours
well
they were all press related um you know
he's done this story he's working on the
story on on
on fbi wiretapping uh do not
do not uh cooperate
even even uh here's a photograph of him
you know in case you see him this is
what he looks like that sort of thing
did they did he think or did the fbi
think that those files would ever be
available to the public no way you know
the freedom of information act had not
been passed then and
they thought that these files would
never be seen by the public uh
some of them
for example in the cointelpro program
that the fbi
mounted which was a method of trying to
disrupt political dissidence what does
that mean by the way black intel pro
yeah it was uh based on
uh the concept that the fbi would use
counterintelligence methods
to in a proactive way to disrupt
political dissidence and
counterintelligence methods normally are
directed against foreign spies not
against americans
but there was a break-in in the media
pennsylvania
office the fbi called the resident
agency
and
a lot of those files were taken and then
they were mailed anonymously to various
newspapers
and that
started to uh
open up the fact uh to the public that
the fbi had been engaging in these kinds
of of improper activities um
and so um
that is how some of these files you know
did in fact get out early on
you men mentioned effort zemless jr
his daughter stephanie zimbalis is
part of your book in los angeles
stalking case what was that about
uh she was the victim of of one of these
typical
star stalkers who would um
become fixated on her and and
constantly write her letters uh showing
that he actually had trailed her all
over the world and they were somewhat
threatening in tone
uh so
she called the fbi herself not she
didn't have
her famous father do it in fact at first
she didn't want her father to know about
it and the los angeles office the fbi uh
got on the case they had never before
actually gotten involved in star stalker
cases they had thought of it as a local
jurisdiction but the fbi if it really
wants to can assume jurisdiction uh
almost any any time it wants for example
in the uh wayne williams uh killings in
atlanta where all those children were
were killed that was a local case but
you know the mayor and the uh governor
appealed to carter and to griffen bell
the attorney general to get the fbi into
it and the fbi made up this reason to
get into it which was that one of the
bodies had not been found and maybe
therefore it had been taken over state
lines and so therefore they they assumed
jurisdiction because of the crossing of
state lines but they knew that it that
the body probably had not been taken
over state lines but they solved the
case
in the zimbalist case
the fbi
really got into star stalker cases at
that point and just did a really good
job
of tracking the suspect
who
mentioned too many places where he had
been watching
the actress too many hotels quote him in
a postcard he says
are you quote gardner
here uh i'm not sure who gardner was
she was the case agent karen garner
i matched her travel schedule from 1997
on gardner said when he said
meaning the stalker
you were in dallas on june 13th she was
in dallas on june 13th even in pulling
the hotel records when he said you were
on the 14th floor she was it was very
real
how did they
this particular stalker was definitely
stephanie zimbles how how long did he
stalk her
i think it went over a period of several
years actually and it started building
up and that's when she started to really
get scared what were the techniques that
they used in order to get him
uh in order to track
his whereabouts they found
they got records from from airlines to
see if he had been on them and what what
flights he was on uh records from hotels
and they just sort of began to
you know pull it all together and and it
started to point to
to this one individual who in turn had
been involved in some previous law
enforcement problem involving threats to
i believe a professor
so they felt that they had the right
person and then
they actually were able to uh
track his whereabouts to
another location where where the actress
was and they saw they
they followed him when the fbi follows
someone uh you know it's not just one
one agent following the the person it's
it may be five or six or seven agents
and they're just dressed in plain
clothes and they may be in ice cream
trucks or bulldozers and they may also
also have a plane overhead so there's
you know quite a bit of sophisticated
surveillance involved and
they actually they watched
this individual uh mail a postcard in a
mailbox and they were able to open the
mailbox again with with uh court
authority and retrieve the postcard and
sure enough it was a postcard to
uh the actress with more threats so they
really you know they really had a lot of
evidence and they they finally did
arrest him uh in his hotel and he
actually uh confessed to some degree you
know he claimed he wasn't going to kill
her or anything like that although it
turned out that he had all kinds of
weapons in his in his home
uh but he uh he made a confession and he
was sent to jail 578 agents in los
angeles and you say that uh
the bank robbery capital of the world
certainly of this country anyway uh
it's uh you know no one's quite sure why
uh
it's just a combination of the sort of
easy access out there to freeways people
can get away easily
the banks out there
tend not to believe in
banded barriers so-called which are
bulletproof glass partitions between the
customer and the and the teller a lot of
other banks don't use them either but
but especially in california they like
this free and easy attitude and of
course you know that's that's rather
silly the the
fdic which insures banks requires all
kinds of other devices and banks like
alarms and and vaults and yet they don't
require banded barriers which cost a
little more money but but not only save
money but save lives
the budget for the fbi for a year
oh it's roughly 2 billion and
this
agent force of 10 300 compares with
about 30 000 police officers in new york
city
how many directors have there been let's
see i guess have been five uh including
the new one uh that counting
el patrick gray and william reckless
exactly
actual directors
uh hoover was director for 48 years so
that took 48 years right when did he
when did the fbi start and when did he
when did he leave
uh he became director in 1924. before
that
it was an arm of the justice department
and had various different names i
believe it started in 1908
and then he died he died in office in
1972.
then what happened
well uh the fbi started to
get out of this
this mold of of on the one hand going
after car thieves and on the other hand
engaging in in illegal practices and and
keeping files on on not only members of
congress for black male purposes but
also uh files on writers and and
actresses and uh you know ernest
hemingway uh it was essentially a
thought police a national thought police
and everyone knew that um if they said
anything uh that was contrary to
government government policy or
certainly criticized the fbi they would
end up in the files and and this might
leak out etc and even if it didn't the
perception was enough to to keep some
people many people in fear
but clarence kelly who became director
uh started this process towards
modernizing the fbi and then william
webster really got it going he really
started the fbi focusing on these
complex investigations
that are sensitive and take many years
and abscam was one example
which resulted in convictions of members
of congress uh a very
controversial
investigation which which uh provoked
some criticism in congress as you can
imagine uh but a very important one
obviously because
you know politicians can't be exempt
from
from the laws um
and then uh william sessions uh
tried to
emphasize the administrative side and
the personnel side he tried to
modernize the fbi uh in its
record-keeping
practice practices for example uh the
fbi would would keep all these uh
duplicate records for no reason and and
just had done many things the same way
they were doing it under hoover he did
talk a lot about
promoting equality within the fbi but
basically he just continued the
policy of hiring more minorities and
more females that webster had started
on the back of the book
it says ronald kessler the fbi inside
the world's most powerful law
enforcement agency by the award-winning
journalists whose investigation brought
down fbi director william s sessions
when you see that on the back of the
book what's your reaction
my reaction
i think we had a good
i had a good editor who came up with
that do you agree with that language
well that's what the
the just department report by the office
of professional responsibility which was
used by clinton uh to uh as a basis for
firing sessions said that the
investigation started with with a letter
that i wrote and also an anonymous
letter which obviously was related to my
letter because it was dated this the day
after my letter was received by the fbi
let's go back to the beginning when did
you start this book
well in some ways i started you know 30
years ago when i started my career
because i've been doing fbi related
stories and books for a long time and
including spy versus spy which is on the
fbi's counterintelligence program and is
the most secret part of the fbi but uh i
started it uh two years ago
and uh did it full time for a year and
then quite a bit
subsequent to that in the second year
before we get into the specifics of this
book
where are you from
i was born in new york and brought up in
belmont mass outside of boston
the john
john birch society was based there that
was the only interesting thing we had
there and uh
then i uh
went to
clarke university where uh in worcester
mass
left after two years because i became
very involved in in newspaper and i was
editor of my school paper and then
started working part time and then full
time for the local paper the worcester
telegram and just decided that i could
sort of learn more on my own by
interviewing people by reading
for stories that i prepare
than being told what to learn
and perhaps the fact that my
parents were all academics contributed
to this where
my father was
a cancer researcher at columbia
medical school and
college of physicians and surgeons and
my stepfather was a physicist at mit
my mother is a musician not in the
academic world but
i guess i'd have my fill of
of academics at that point
who or when did you get interested in
journalism
i had started on my
sunday school newspaper in fact i
started the sunday school newspaper in
belmont mass bethel temple center and
then
um was that an editor of my high school
paper belmont high school newspaper and
then
at the clark scarlett which was the
college newspaper
and then i started working for worcester
telegram and then the boston herald the
wall street journal and then the
washington post
so i've been
through through the mill as far as
newspapers go did you by the way have
any any
access to the john birch society being
based there and now uh now i guess i did
try to interview them at some point
perhaps for the for the school paper i
think i did
and
some of the some of the
students picketed
the john birch society i did stories
about that
but
i guess i
knew as a journalist that you know you
you don't get involved in political
activities at that you know like that
you you stay
uh you remain as a journalist and just
disinterested and just write about what
other people do how many books have you
written
this will be my eighth book the fbi one
was the first one
the first one was uh i believe
1984
which was on the life insurance industry
and and uh how it works and and how it
rips people off
when did you leave the washington post
officially in 1987 but i've been on
leave for three years before that
why did you leave
i left because i started writing books
and and enjoyed it you know it was a way
of getting in more in depth into into
subjects
and
it's it's fun
in the introduction and in the last part
of the book a lot is spent on william
sessions um
let's let's go back to that when you
decided to write this book
where did you start
asking for access
i went to the fbi uh after my agent
robert garley had come up come up with
the idea and i went to the pr people and
said you know i'd like to do this book
and
you know and they said oh great we went
out to lunch
but it turned out that um
their idea of access was was a very
limited one that they wanted to really
control the book and and uh
that i would have to go through them
before interviewing anybody they would
sit in on the interviews they would
decide who uh who was who should be
interviewed for what subjects on and on
and on and it was much more
even more restrictive than than any
other
uh
dealings i had had with the fbi so
uh finally it all came to a head when
it turned out that they heard that i had
been interviewing bill baker who was
then over the criminal division of the
fbi and that they had not been told
about it
baker had previously written a memo to
them saying that they should cooperate
in his opinion that he had dealt with me
a lot both at the fbi and at the cia
where he had worked for webster as his
pr person
but but they were telling me that i
uh that i should tell bill baker the
assistant director of the fbi to notify
them that he was being interviewed it
was a crazy situation and so i finally
called baker at home on sunday and dealt
with him uh you know
on that basis before and told him what
was happening in fact the pr people said
if you do call anybody including baker
without telling us you know we're not
going to cooperate anymore it was it was
just ludicrous
but i did call baker and
told him what was happening and he said
he'll take care of it you know he was a
is a sophisticated
agent and uh
well-versed in public affairs both at
the cia and the fbi and uh and he he
said that he realized that if this book
were to be credible and and and read
that it would have to have all awards
and and to have that as he put it i
would have to be able to test what the
fbi tells me by having this free access
uh so
he took care of it he talked to jim
greenleaf who was
uh then associate deputy director who
also
had dealt with me before and they both
went to floyd clark
who was
who is the deputy director of the fbi
and he in turn recommended his sessions
that they really opened the doors and
that's what happened sessions sent a
teletype to all of the 23 000 fbi
employees
saying that that the fbi is cooperating
on this book and outlining
terms that that did give me this free
access so that i could call
people freely i didn't have to tell
anybody
and
i could interview people without pr
people being present
it really gave me exactly what i needed
to do the book
and they go back to the back of this
book inside the world's most powerful
law enforcement agency by the
award-winning journalists whose
investigation brought down fbi director
william s sessions
he gave you the access unlimited access
and this book then brought him down how
in the course of doing the book about
three or four months after i had started
i got a tip from a long-term source
perhaps we could call him deep bureau
who
mentioned
one aspect of these abuses that were
going on
which had to do with the fact that
sessions was trying to award a hundred
thousand dollar contract for
security at his home in washington to
uh a person in san antonio who just
happened to be the husband of his then
long-term administrative assistant sarah
munford and
i was able to confirm that with another
fbi official and then i asked sessions
about it in one of my interviews with
him
and
i had about four interviews with him and
i went to new york with him on his on
the fbi plane with his wife alice and
and uh
so
he responded by saying oh yes that was
ron
mccall who was this low-level
security uh person over over the uh
director's security detail that was his
decision to
give the contract to the husband of his
assistant well he didn't have to know
anything about this to realize that of
course that was disingenuous and
that just set off all the alarm bells in
my head
uh as as an investigative reporter for a
long time uh
if anything indicated there was
something wrong there that that was it
for the director to to claim that that
it was the decision of this low-level
guy to to award the sweetheart contract
was obviously
uh untrue so let me go let me just
interrupt to go back so we can get it
clear um sarah munford
did what for fbi director sessions she
had been his administrative assistant
for a long time even going back to when
he was chief judge of the federal court
in uh san antonio and she had caused a
tremendous number of problems and and in
the fbi uh had abused her authority she
had
and this is part of the abuses that i
that i got into subsequently uh she
used her fbi credentials to try to get
off on a ticket
when she was stopped in texas by a state
trooper
she
and she berated this trooper for for
even stopping her because she's the
assistant to the fbi director
she also continued to register her car
in texas even though she'd been living
in virginia for five years working for
sessions
and again that's a violation of law and
if any fbi agent had done that they
would be severely disciplined and yet
sessions was aware of it and had allowed
it to continue how do you know he was
aware of it
uh i talked to his wife alice and she
said that they were aware of it
they they socialized a lot you know they
saw uh her car and there have been you
know some complaints in fact
high-ranking fbi officials had brought
many of these matters to the attention
of sessions over the years warning him
that that if he continues that he might
lose his directorship and and he
continued anyway who would warn a
director who has the nerve to go in and
tell their boss that they got problems
it's done you know very very uh gently
uh and and not as a big list of all
these abuses you're engaging in but
rather you know by the way
this this is the rule on this matter
buck revell had written a letter
a memo to
sessions about the use of the fbi
security detail almost as soon as
sessions took over because sessions
wanted to use a detail to pick up his
father at the airport and things like
that and that's an improper use of the
detail it's not a taxi service uh so and
that that memo for example is is in the
files
go back to you said you went to new york
with uh director sessions on his plane
on the fbi plan right um and his wife
was with you that's right did you have
to pay for that trip yes unfortunately
what's it cost for you to ride with the
fbi director i paid the shuttle price
from washington to new york why did he
take you with him uh i had asked to go
on a trip with him just to depict how
how he takes his trips what he does etc
in this case he was he'd given out
awards uh to fbi agents in new york
uh one female agent had had um
almost single-handedly warded off some
thugs who were armed who were after some
new york city detectives for example
i
came up with a number of other
methods of getting inside the bureau
like
sitting on on sessions meetings with his
assistant directors uh
at a breakfast meeting and and
i went to uh
to see a wiretap room where they monitor
conversations and and also uh
a secret fbi airport where they keep
their little air force which is used for
surveillance they let you see all this
they did
why were they letting you do this
very uh
i was sly i guess um but why do you
think they were letting you do this i
mean didn't you have questions all along
and said this has never happened before
no reporter's been here before
you know it was a combination of of
things i think it was uh
which which frequently happens
in when you do a book where you where
you want the cooperation of the subject
but you also want to remain independent
uh and
and what you do is you try to
get enough access so that they realize
that they might as well cooperate more
because they'll look better but at the
same time
if there's anything
that's improper
presumably you'll find it
in this case
i don't think that sessions
ever thought that i would ever get you
know get into his abuses
you know even after i wrote a letter to
him outlining these abuses and and he
knew he was being investigated
investigated by the justice department
over these abuses he continued to engage
in them which tells me that he was so
arrogant about them that that he never
thought you know anything of it let me
just clear some of it has he ever been
charged yet with any violation of the
law
he's not been charged criminally but the
justice department is billing him thirty
thousand dollars uh
which can be collected in a civil action
if necessary for uh some of these some
of these matters uh namely the use of
the fbi plane for personal trips and
also uh the installation of a ten
thousand dollar fence on his property
which was supposed to be for security
and was paid for by the taxpayers as a
security device and but in fact did not
enhance security at all would it be
normal though for an fbi director
security defense to be paid for by the
government
yeah the government would pay for
security devices at his home as long as
they were reasonable and really would
enhance security the same thing happened
with webster when he was director so
what's the difference between william
wester having a security defense around
his place and a 10 000 defense dollar
fence around mr sessions the difference
is the kind of fence the security people
said that the proper kind of fence was
one that the white house has and
embassies in washington have which are
uh
steel and and have little
uh
very small slats so that you can see all
the way through them from any angle
whereas the fence that was installed
even though it has slats and it's wooden
you can't see through from any angle and
therefore
someone who might want to
kill the director let's say could be
lurking behind the fence and the
security people couldn't see that person
um
you've been around this town for a long
time you know that there have been a lot
of things going on with public officials
that you've written about is is this so
far enough to to
say that the fbi director ought to be
removed from what you've heard well a
lot of public officials have been
removed from much less for example john
sununu was kicked out of the white house
for taking you know some planning trips
that were
uh much more minor compared with the
plane trips that that sessions took
sessions uh
every other month would go back to texas
to his home state and he'd make up some
some excuse like he's going to talk to a
rotary club and then he'd go to san
francisco to see his daughter he'd go
to atlantic city to see a ballet and all
this was a taxpayer expense one thousand
dollars an hour is what the cost of fbi
plane is but that was only part of the
abuses
i mentioned the sarah munford abuses
that he condone
he also gave an fbi building passed to
his wife alice when you have to have a
top secret security clearance to have
that passed by federal regulation so
members of congress and white house
aides and journalists who come to the
fbi building have to all be signed in
and escorted up but but only
his wife alice was allowed to just walk
in at will with this pass if fbi agents
forget their pass uh you know their
their their discipline their there's a
letter in their file etc and yet uh
she was able to to you know have this
privilege uh
just because she was the director's wife
uh there was also a sweetheart mortgage
on his home that came out later uh
because he was fbi director he was given
uh a special deal on the on the interest
rate and the and the points by riggs
national bank because sessions had
talked to the
uh
the chairman of the board of riggs
joseph
right how do you know this this was uh
detailed in the in the opr report the
office of professional responsibility uh
and at at first sessions wouldn't even
provide the mortgage documents
uh for the investigators you know which
is which is sort of the attack taken by
people who are being investigated by the
fbi
uh and then when it all
came out and the report came out
sessions
claimed that he had never been given a
chance to give his side which was untrue
it's been four days being interviewed by
the opr people and also i've seen the
response that he's given to the opr
report which is a very detailed
line-by-line
rebuttal which which is totally
ineffective but but he uh you know when
he said that he had never had a chance
to to actually respond
that was another disingenuous response
what was your relationship with him and
mrs session
from the beginning how did what happened
to that relationship
when i first went into it i you know i
had this image of that most people had i
think of of this former federal judge
who probably was something like william
webster the the other director who had
been a judge before him
and then when i met him you know he
seemed extremely affable uh you know
very very
nice kind of person
uh
and uh as i got into these abuses you
know of course i was very puzzled and
and tried to uh
figure it out in my mind uh how could
this person who's so affable and and
and seemed so caring uh and stood for uh
equality uh also be so blind to to the
fact that he was engaging in wrongdoing
and
what i started to learn was that he was
also rather arrogant he would he would
for example when being briefed by fbi
agents about very uh sensitive
investigations he would just
start singing the brill cream commercial
for example
that's just one you know quirky example
and then when he was introduced to a
chinese diplomat
he said there was no need for an
interpreter
he speaks chinese and then he started
saying chop suey chow mein you know i
think that that indicates arrogance and
and there was a certain nastiness to him
i thought because
when he finally did
respond to my letter outlining these
abuses and he wouldn't comment on them
or or answer any questions but he he
bought me out for looking into these
matters at all or any embarrassing
matters at the fbi uh he
started
comparing himself with some of the other
directors and he said
that uh other directors wives had been
sick or or had died
that william webster's wife drew you
know had died well she died you know
what
he apparently was was criticizing
webster because his wife had died and
and and clarence kelly uh the other
director because his wife was sick you
know in fact webster's wife drew uh was
dearly loved by the fbi uh and respected
by the fbi and and uh had been uh was
alive for the first six years of of
webster's term and and so
i think there was a nastiness to to his
um
his outlook uh
which was compounded by his wife alice
who had this very paranoid view of
almost anything you know people were out
to get her in fact she told me that
the fbi was was bugging her
and
the fbi could do nothing right uh why
why would she feel that way
i i think it it has to do with her her
uh her just her mindset um
that that's the kind of personality she
she is
she would imagine all kinds of things
for example she
kept saying and sessions kept
apparently ratifying
that ron mccall this low-level security
agent had been found by her in their
bedroom and without their permission you
know and that was just a total
fabrication it never happened uh the the
fbi
uh internal investigators looked into
that and they found that there was a
previous incident involving his his
predecessor who had gone to the house
with sessions permission
to change the code on the two-way radio
in his bedroom and she came home and saw
him and uh and he said you know the
sessions that said
it's okay and and that was it but she
made it made it into this great
conspiracy involving ron mccall who had
never done anything wrong except to
question some of the
uh abuses that she
tried to get the fbi to engage in one of
the things that's difficult is that mr
sessions isn't here to defend himself
and neither is she did you try at any
point
to get them to talk to you about these
abuses
these alleged abuses they still have not
been charged as far as i know
well you know it's not a criminal matter
i mean there are a range of there's a
range of wrongdoing and abuse that can
occur without it being a criminal case
and in this case uh the office of
professional responsibility of the
justice department wrote a report which
which confirmed these matters and found
that they were even more serious than i
thought
and uh when
the pres when the president fired him
he
and janet reno said that
they had found that based on this report
that he had a serious problem with
judgment and that therefore he was being
dismissed
um has he ever told his side of the
story oh yeah he's been on tv uh you
know on radio and and and been
interviewed
uh constantly and then does he answer
the specific charges
well he's he's addressed them he's been
asked about them i don't think you know
in my opinion that he actually has has
answered them uh honestly he's
come up with all these
excuses he's claimed that it was a great
cabal that was out to get him it was
either the democrats
or the republicans or it was hoover
rights and the fbi or bigots or
or me who was being used as a as a dupe
and a pawn of these hoover rights
and it's all
fabrication what'd they do when he left
when he left i mean what's he doing now
um i don't know i don't you know i think
he's looking for a job basically
normally by the way how old a man is he
uh
perhaps
probably ryan is i think he might be
around 60 roughly
here's what the book looks like
and i want to show once we see the cover
on the screen i want to open it up so
you can
see inside this picture normally it
authors tell you that it takes nine
months to get a book
printed after you've finished it and
here you've already got a picture of the
new fbi director who just
recently took the oath how did you get
it in here so fast
i had really finished the manuscript a
year before and but then i kept updating
it and adding to it quite extensively
including
5000 words on the waco incident alone uh
and then it was already in bound galley
form when clinton fired the director
so at that point the publisher
pocketbooks decided to
crash it and bring it out within three
weeks and within a day or two i wrote an
additional portion which was another i
think two thousand three thousand words
about the firing we put in the latest
photographs and uh three weeks later it
was in the bookstores is that i mean is
it is that the the quickest you've ever
had any book published oh yeah you know
i am used to this very long gestation
period which is frustrating for a former
newspaper reporter uh of course ideally
i would have liked to have had all these
abuses in my book and have it all come
out at that at the time the book comes
out that's what you know the normal
situation would be but but what happened
was that
after i wrote this letter the ten page
letter which which i wrote because
sessions uh
uh didn't initially want to be
interviewed about the abuses
and the pr people said well at first
well this isn't really important enough
to bother the director with and and then
they said we'll write this letter
outlining what you want to talk about
and then we'll see about an interview so
i wrote this 10-page single-spaced
letter
outlining the abuses sent it to the fbi
pr people unbeknownst to me they turned
it over
to the justice department for
investigation the very same day
and that's what started the
investigation sessions did finally meet
with me but didn't discuss you know the
specifics wouldn't answer the questions
obviously that would have been an
opportunity for him to give his side and
and to stop the abuses but he didn't he
continued
uh and then
sam donaldson last october
uh broke the story on abc of the fact
that the just sperm was investigating
sessions so it all came out then or at
least that portion of it came out then
how did sam donaldson get the story
well uh you know i say in the book that
that
he definitely did talk to alice sessions
before he did his story so she clearly
was at least a source i don't know where
he originally heard about it but
sessions
made a uh
a point of saying that this
the fact that this had leaked was was
more evidence that it was a great cabal
by the attorney general then william
barr to get him but in fact alice
sessions contributed to it
you know there's a lot more in this book
besides william sessions that we spend a
lot of time on and the time remaining i
want to ask you some quick questions
you've titled the washington office
chapter watergate uh deep throat what's
the point
that uh one of the major investigations
that the washington office undertook was
the watergate investigation uh that it
was of course the fbi that that did the
investigation of watergate that resulted
in the convictions
woodward and bernstein did a fantastic
investigative job both getting leaks out
of that investigation and doing their
own job but it was actually the fbi that
that did the main investigation
you say at one point um
that two names have been surfaced
as who deep throat is and published one
of them was hugh sloane and i can't
remember the other one
maybe you can is that was that field
was another one well
that's not the name you had in here but
the point i want to ask you about is
that i'm looking for it um
did you feel that
when that was published those names were
published
that it got widespread publicity or did
you just pick it up on a story that
didn't get much mentioned
about who deep throat is um
there have been a number of names you
know floated and and the other one i'm
sorry is judy hobach a bookkeeper for
the committee for the re-election the
president
and you referenced an ap story in 1992.
yeah the the point of that was it was
simply that that as we bernstein wrote
in their book all the president's men
they had a number of sources uh deep
throat was one of them but everyone
became fixated on on that because of the
name and that there are other sources
who've since come forward and been
identified houston was one of them and
nobody cared because they didn't have a
great name
you know deep throat wasn't very
important but but there are other
important sources as well you dedicate
the book for pam greg and rachel kessler
who are they
my wife pam and my daughter rachel and
my son greg how old are they not your
wife necessarily but how are the kids
my son is 26 he's an artist in new york
and my daughter rachel is 24 and she's
at the wall street journal washington
bureau doing what she's a news assistant
and writing stories on the side as well
and hoping to be a reporter does your
wife work
she is an author also she's a former
washington post reporter now writing
books she wrote a book about the spy
sites of washington and she's written a
novel now and pocket books who are they
that's part of simon schuster
they like to be identified as just
pocket books not simon schuster because
they're almost in competition with each
other but
uh
my editor there is paul mccarthy who
really had a lot to do with
getting this book out
and
making it what it is in the back you
have 504
notes um you did it in kind of a
different way i mean you actually go
from one to 504 instead of doing it by
chapter was that your idea
uh yeah and you know with word perfect
it's much easier to just go
like that chronologically
and i think it's easier for people to
pick out the notes that way how many
interviews did you do for this book
there were 314 people interviewed mostly
agents who were current some former
agents some other employees as well did
you interview them on audio tape
yes everyone except for a few very
sensitive ones were tape recorded with
people's permission what do you do with
the tape
that's in a bank fault what are you
going to do with that
i usually keep it for several years and
then
and then re-record for the next book is
there another book underway already
yes but if you don't mind i'd like to
keep that quiet it's about another
very secretive very powerful institution
uh and it'll be out next year
and uh
investigative reporting obviously is
your thing
you have any idea where you first got
interested in that part of journalism
investigative reporting
i i recall uh you know my
temple newspaper uh
doing a story about um the blue laws of
massachusetts and and quoting
a number of clergymen as saying that
even they didn't think that they were
necessary
and i remember that as being
something that i liked to do because
it contributed to public understanding
perhaps
would lead to some reforms uh
got to the heart of the
of the truth in this particular case and
so that was a very minor example and
then when i was on my college paper
clark
i did a story
uh about uh discrimination against
blacks they were called negros in those
days
in rental housing and to do that i would
call various people who would advertise
their homes for for rent and i would say
is it still open they would say yes and
i would say by the way my roommate is
black is that a problem and 60 said yes
that would be a problem
and that led to quite a few
investigations in massachusetts and
so
things like that
sort of wetted my appetite i like to
get involved in controversial things but
but more so to get to the truth one of
the things that i uh you know new thing
that i learned in here and explain it
was that
if you're an agent and you're gaining
access to i'm not sure what building or
what place you look into something and
they read your eyes what's that uh it's
an optical
uh
scanner
which detects the pattern of
blood vessels in your eye
i guess in the retina or some place and
each person has a unique pattern
so they record that in the computer and
then
in order to gain access to the building
you look into a little
uh
optical piece which
senses the same pattern and if if you're
the same person it lets you in
there's a lot more and we only have a
minute can you give us
to finalize this
your attitude about the fbi after
spending all this time looking into how
it operates
i have a greater appreciation both for
the successes and for the problems and
the negative aspect
before i started this book
you know i thought they did a pretty
good job but i wasn't aware of all the
the personnel problems you know ranging
from uh agents who would go to wife
swapping parties and and sex clubs in
miami who are married to each other
to a polygraph examiner who
fabricated the reports of his
examinations and also an fbi agent who
was a safe cracker for the fbi but was
found in the credit union of the fbi at
headquarters after hours with the vault
open and and failed a lie detector test
on whether he was there to to break in
and take the money um those are things
that i certainly was not aware of uh but
i also
have a greater appreciation for the
successes and the amazing techniques
that the fbi has
for example they're taught in training
to
look for certain body language that
might indicate whether a person is lying
or not and i've tested and i think it
generally seems to work and that is
if you ask a right-hand right-handed
person
uh
a question and that person looks to the
right
invariably he's
genuinely trying to tell the truth and
if you ask someone you know who is your
second or third grade teacher in school
they'll search their mind and they'll go
off to the right if they're right-handed
if they're left-handed it's the opposite
but if they're right-handed and they
look to the left then they are lying
that part is harder to test because you
know you don't know if a person is lying
or not but but you know
the other part i've tested
the rest you're going to have to find in
the book itself ron kessler is the
author and the book looks like this it's
called the fbi thank you very much for
joining us thanks brian
ronald kessler is the new york times
best-selling author of 18 non-fiction
books in 1968 he reported for the new
york bureau of the wall street journal
he became an investigative reporter with
the new york post in 1970 and continued
as a staff writer until 1985. he has
also won 16 journalism awards for more
information visit ronkler.com